the rise of Skywalker is filled with
plot twists and references that only
older fans will get as well as some
disturbing ideas that only mature
viewers will notice children will enjoy
the Skywalker sagas finale just fine but
will they pick up on these plot points
we think not spoilers ahead so let's
talk about the rise of Skywalker's big
secrets Reyes Palpatine's granddaughter
surprise and maybe not abrams has been
hinting that he undid the last Jedi's
nobody twists for a while now and leaks
about Rey's true heritage have been
circulating on the internet for months
but a Palpatine has a granddaughter that
means he has a kid if you're old enough
to know the story of the birds and the
bees you know that means old wrinkly
yellow eyed Palpatine played a little
dingdong ping-pong with some lucky lady
he's fully operational if you catch our
drift
unfortunately the rise of Skywalker
doesn't reveal the identity of
Palpatine's lover or children leaving
the comics and novels to explain those
mysteries that's too bad because we'd
love to meet the woman who got seduced
by those shapeless black robes we bet
she has some interesting stories to tell
it took 11 films but there's finally a
canonical same-sex couple on-screen in a
Star Wars movie no it's not the sequel
trilogies most dynamic couple Finn and
Poe Dameron it's Commander dossie one of
the top-ranking resistance officers and
her wife a resistance fighter named ro
beat ice who locked lips while the
resistance is celebrating the defeat of
Palpatine
kids probably won't even notice the
moment which is over almost as soon as
it begins but adults will certainly
realize with the inclusion of a same-sex
couple and a Star Wars feature film
means over the past four decades Star
Wars has been remarkably conservative
when it comes to depicting relationships
but most adults will also realize that
it's a very small step simply showing
two women kissing isn't real
representation bossy isn't a real
character in the film we don't know
where hopes dreams motivations or fears
heck we barely even know what she sounds
like
dossie was a good start but Disney and
Lucasfilm still have a long way to go
even if children are aware of carrie
fisher's passing they're probably not
going to give too much thought to how
Leia returns for the rise of Skywalker
there's too much else going on for those
of us who grew up with Princess Leia
however it's almost impossible not to
think about Fisher's death in 2016
every time her most famous creation
shows up on screen as such adults are
probably going to notice all the tricks
that JJ Abrams and the rise of Skywalker
crew used to give Leia the send-off she
deserves as promised
Abrams used outtakes from the force
awakens and the last Jedi and Leia
scenes not a digital recreation you can
tell
Leia's lines are noticeably bang it's up
to her seeing partners to deliver the
specifics given the situation it
actually works pretty well Leia is the
heart of this movie and it's wonderful
to get a chance to say goodbye
but the sleight-of-hand is something
most adults will definitely notice
c-3po gets the rise of Skywalker's best
lines but one of the movie's funniest
moments doesn't have any words at all it
comes at the very end of the movie as
everyone celebrates Poe Dameron sees his
old friends Orry bliss they lock eyes
Poe gives Orry an inviting tilt of his
head
sori shakes him off Poe looks
disappointed the audience percent -
laughter the subtext should go right
over kids heads but every adult in the
theater will realize that Poe is asking
Zoe if she wanted to get busy they'll
also know that sori completely shut him
down now well there's no harm in trying
look Poe just defeated an entire fleet
of stardestroyers he won the war
emotions are riding high who can blame
him for calling up an ex to blow off
some steam rey finn and post quest takes
them to the planet Posada where a
festival is taking place the party c-3po
explains is thrown by the Posada natives
the Aki Aki and is held once every 42
years if you're one of the lucky young
uns who grew up in an age when new Star
Wars movies have been a thing that
number won't mean anything to you if
you've been following the Skywalker saga
since the very beginning you should know
immediately how Abrams and his co-writer
Chris Terrio landed on 42 Star Wars
Episode four a new folk came out in 1977
Star Wars Episode nine the rise of
Skywalker came out in 2019 guess how
many years apart that is
forty-two maybe that's a clue for the
future to Disney says that its next Star
Wars film will debut in 2022 so you
might as well go ahead and set aside
some time in 2060 for now you'll
certainly want to see how the next saga
ends the rise of Skywalker reveals that
before he joined the resistance Poe
Dameron used to run spice the way the
other characters react it's not a good
thing but it doesn't sound so bad
who doesn't add a pinch of cumin or
paprika to their dishes while they cook
even in space food should taste good
except that's not the kind of spice
they're talking about just from the
language used as well as the precedent
set by Frank Herbert's dune mature
members of the audience who don't
already know will quickly figure out
that in Star Wars spice is basically
slang for drugs he who controls the
spice controls a university
Poe Dameron wasn't helping people season
their meals he was profiting off of
other people's addictions in the Star
Wars universe the drug trade is just as
vicious and exploitative as it is in
real life it's not a good thing for
someone like Poe to be involved in of
course in his prime the renowned
scoundrel han Solo was known to smuggle
spice - no wonder Leia likes him check
out one of our newest videos right here
Plus even more looper videos about your
favorite Star Wars stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]